- Live and direct from Hollywood.
- How do you find the
best taco in Los Angeles?
- We're gonna play a little
game of Taco Truck Telephone.
- Taco Telephone.
- So we wanna find the best tacos.
- And what better way to do
that than to go to a taco truck.
- And at that taco vending establishment
we are going to ask them
what they think is the best
taco truck and go to that
taco truck and ask them--
- What their favorite taco truck is.
- And then we're gonna
just keep hopping around
until we find--
- The absolute finest taco
in the county of Los Angeles.
- And we're also gonna eat some tacos,
judging for ourselves,
who has the best tacos.
(Latin music)
- [Man] How many different
kinds of tacos do you have?
- Okay, we will get one of each.
Let's test it out and
see what we got here.
- Double wrap is what you need.
- Tortillas on there.
There's a lot of cheese on mine.
- Al pastor taco.
- Al pastor.
- Oh no, I can't go with that one, no.
- Why?
- Beans.
- You don't like beans?
- Uh uh.
- Guy doesn't eat beans,
he's on a taco adventure.
- Cheers.
- Mmm.
- Not bad, right?
- Cactus makes a good taco.
- Yeah, so we got the two
beef left after Freddie
massacred this chicken taco.
- [Steven] That's so good.
That is deli-- that is like...
- This sauce is incredible.
- It's whimsical.
- Whimsical?
- Has a kick.
- Mmmhmm.
Whew!
And then I have one question for you.
If you aren't eating tacos
here, where is your favorite
place to eat tacos in Los Angeles?
(laughs)
- This is it.
I mean we're starting off
on a really strong foot.
I don't know if any other
places can top these,
but we'll see.
- Hey, if there's one thing
that I've learned about
Los Angeles, never
underestimate the Valley.
And that's where we're headed next.
(tapping)
- What?
- You gonna make it?
- Yeah, I'll make it.
I'm just getting over the taco coma.
- What could happen at the next taco place
that would make it better?
- I fall in love with
the man cooking the tacos
(laughter)
- Alright, we have a new
mission for this video guys.
- [Freddie] I think that'd make it--
I think that would make the video.
- [Colin] We are cabeza, buche--
- [Freddie] Chorizo.
- [Colin] Chorizo, lengua, and birria.
- [Andrew] It's so good.
I've never had a taco
that offered like this breadth of meat.
- This is chorizo?
- [Freddie] Yeah.
- You're doing the chorizo right now.
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
- [Freddie] Chorizo...
- That is whimsical
times a million. (laughs)
- [Colin] My God.
(Freddie laughs)
Whimsical times a million.
- That's like not even whimsical anymore.
- Wow, the seasoning.
- [Steven] I know right?
- I mean, it's like--
- Let me at it.
Oh yeah, that's a killer chorizo.
Rigo's Tacos gets a
enthusiastic thumbs up.
- [Andrew] And it's covered in cactus.
- [Freddie] Sorry cactus.
So what we do is we're going
to different taco vendors,
restaurants, and trucks.
We're asking them where they
like to eat tacos in LA.
- Hmmm, let me think about that.
He says El Taurino in Van Nuys.
- Nice, thank you.
So our next stop is--
- El Taurino.
- [Freddie] I haven't reached
the pinnacle of fullness yet.
I think after the next place
I might be slowing down.
Steven doesn't look like he agrees.
- I could eat tacos for days.
What is in this meat?
Oh! Oh my gosh!
Give me 10 more of those.
- Tongue, ta tongue tongue.
- Get dirty on that lengua.
(laughter)
- [Steve] Oh gosh, yeah!
Didn't think I'll be ever
saying that I like tongue but
that was a good tongue taco.
- Oh man!
- [Freddie] Is this the spicy one?
- Yeah, it's hugely hot.
Oh man!
- Wow, it's sweet.
Like it has a slightly sweet aspect to it
but it's like not overwhelming.
Mouthwatering has started.
- I like how the tacos keep
getting better and better.
- This is working guys.
The Taco Telephone is working.
- When you're not eating your own food
where else do you go?
- Uh, for the booze, Taco's Way.
- Taco's Way serves booze?
- There's booze and
really good micheladas.
- Have any of you ever
had a michelada before?
- [Freddie] No.
- [Colin] None of you?
- [Steven] I don't know what that is.
- [Colin] Oh my god, we have
three people who are gonna
have a michelada for the first time.
Your minds are all gonna be blown.
- To an impressive taco adventure.
- Andrew and Freddie are
gonna have their first
micheladas right now.
- [Freddie] Well I love
beer and I love spices,
I love shrimp.
I mean its kinda all my favorite things.
- That hits the spot.
- Yes michelada.
- Yeah!
- Whoo!
- Carnitas.
- Okay, mind blown.
That's great, that's wonderful.
- Carnitas has the crispy
ends that just makes it.
It's like heaven.
Like pork flavored popcorn in your mouth.
- Mmm. Yeah this is
definitely tongue or head.
- It's something that
came from this region.
- I like it, alot.
It's super tender and like it just
slides on down your throat.
- High fives all around guys.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- We went to progressively
more awesome taco spots
throughout the day.
- You know what I love about this?
I love that like every time
you go to a new place you're
telling them that somebody
else recommended that place.
That's what makes this so great.
- Yeah, they're always thrilled.
- Thanks for tuning in
to another episode of
I don't know what this is called yet.
- Insert name here.
(laughter)
- Yeah right.
- We'll see you next time.
(laughter)
- I wanna do burgers next.
- Can we?
- Sure.
- I'd be down.
- Pastrami sandwiches.
- Dumplings?
- Oh my god we could do dumplings.